do you recognize this man's face if the
answer is no then the answer is going to
be yes by this time next week because
this man is none other than Jamie miles
otherwise known as J Mills and he is
going to be being featured on my channel
Jamie was the original Ox vlogger along
with myself two years ago and he's
coming down to we to to shoot a couple
of videos with me we realize we've never
actually been on camera together before
so um bit late but you know better late
than never so we're going to be doing
some videos together and we'd like those
videos to be question and answer videos
Q&A so in order to do those we need some
questions so please leave in the
comments of this video what you'd like
us to answer on camera and that can be
anything it can be about our life before
Oxford after Oxford our time when we
were there um maybe advice that the two
of us might be able to give you don't
know Jamie's now apparently here we're
going to be filming those this weekend
so get commenting I do have another
exciting announcement for you though as
of this week I am now the co-host of EXA
University's Science Show so EXA has its
own student radio station expression FM
and on Tuesdays from 7: to 8:00 there is
a science show and uh myself and a
lovely PhD student in astrophysics
called Hannah uh we're going to be
running a science show on everything
everything science-based so this week we
going to be doing an hour on the Earth's
atmosphere um next week we're going to
be doing a special program on the
history of Pi and we're going to be
doing a couple of segments on those
themes we're going to be doing a
biography of a scientist who's linked to
to the theme we're talking about we're
going to have science news we're going
to play some music it's going to
hopefully be really really good um I've
never done anything in radio before but
Hannah has so she's hopefully going to
teach me on the job um if you would like
to tweet me at Simon Ox Fizz during that
hour then by all means do because um
it'll be great to hear from you whilst
I'm on a and reassure me that I'm not
doing terribly um if you'd like to
listen live there is a link on the
screen right now and also a link in the
description um for how you can do that
it's totally free um and you can also if
you if you can't make it live you can
watch any of the shows on uh I can't
remember which service it is but there's
a service which they save everything to
so that link is now on the description
now on the screen and also in the
description um it would be fantastic to
have some of you guys there and to have
you have you have you hear what um hear
what they have to say about me being on
radio I'm really excited but quite
nervous so leave your questions in the
comments down below for what you'd like
Jamie I to answer on camera and if you
can tune in on Tuesday 7 till 8 every
Tuesday from now until Christmas to hear
me wble on about science I I I can't
believe I actually just said those two
things that's that's really awesome I'm
doing a YouTube collab and
radio I wouldn't be here without you
guys thank you so much thanks for
watching and I will be seeing you very
shortly to actually I don't know I'll be
sing very shortly either getting my Draw
My Life video out this week which I'd
like to do I realized it's it's a couple
of days late now um or possibly with the
first video with Jamie so we'll see I'll
be seeing you soon thanks for watching